citizens of the reject Nation we're
watching saw Final Chapter it's me and
Aaron
Alexander that was good huh that was
very good people are like put her in a
musical and pay her loads of money right
give her her own show yeah man okay guys
so don't forget as we get into this
leave a like you got to leave a comment
don't forget that you have to ring the
bell ring the bell and get over on
patreon cuz we call you super sexy over
there if you know what's right for you
you got anything to
say Feeling Good Feeling Good ready for
some S I learned that this one was
originally called Saw 3D also known as
saw the Final Chapter so I'm curious to
know if they like had like some major 3D
elements going on obviously we're not
going to get to experience that but yeah
I'm uh I'm curious to see what they do
for this Final Chapter cuz everyone
knows this is the last one we're
watching he just built us up to bring it
all down he's like 3D and then he's like
we don't get to experience it you know
and I'm like I give it to take it away
what was the point of that Aaron just Ed
edicate you and edicate these lovely
people here who already know this thing
all right well now we're going to watch
it the Final
Chapter hello Mr
hle oh we're going we're going back to
the first one yeah okay
hello
okay I know that shirt the shirt you
know the shirt Shir no wait what I
didn't even see I didn't get there was a
blue shirt on the
ground what is
this I think that's oh remember cuz he s
off wait is this the wait a minute oh is
this we seen him since the
I three where like you can't get him cuz
the other guy was in it and he wasn't so
if this is this guy I think it
might is that him is it yes it is him
okay where have you been guys dude he
was the guy that we were like oh they
couldn't get him for three yeah or two I
don't remember cuz the other guy was in
it we haven't seen him since one yeah
yeah okay cuz I was like okay they
showed stuff from the first one so I'm
like okay I know that shirt look
familiar
okay what the oh no oh he's going to
don't do that he's going to oh he's
going to cauterize it oh it's good it's
a great thought you're being smart I
like it I don't want to see it I don't
want to see I don't need
it
no God
that's that is gnarly I could do
that oh God easy I mean I don't know how
how he was still awake and screamy I was
just ah pass out immediately this he's
Wesley he can do anything you're right
you're
right oh oh my God it's like a public
one oh my this is a public game right or
what yes how did oh my God how did you
set how did you even set that up how did
he set exactly like how would you even
and who set it up in the M someone has
to work there it has to be someone who
has access oh this is mucked up what are
you doing here the are you doing here
somebody help us come on help
us oh shoot and there's a girl there oh
my God she going to drop down on the
saws oh
no oh they all know each other this time
okay baby baby oh get me out of here
baby El oh she has two boyfriends two
mans is this a cheating
situation Amry
right oh of course it's like bulletproof
unbreakable glass jigs SAU coming up
it's Billy what the hell what the hell
hello
BR hello ran I'm going to play a game
why are you guys just standing there
call the police or something
manipulating your love for her and
causing nothing but pain she is toxic
and today all of your transgressions
will be me public you must choose who
will drop out of this
triangle within 60 seconds one of you
must die if you wish to save her then
the SS must be pushed all the way to one
side or the other oh who is indeed the
alpha
male are you both strong enough enough
to walk away from what is destroying you
or will you fight one more time for the
heart that binds this toxic is hell wow
okay what a
[Music]
predicament yo this messed up what in
the actual are they doing like a seesaw
with the saws right now yes that's
amazing it's a saw SE saw where
everybody can see them
saw everybody's seeing the Seesaw saw
away in the
Seesaw BR I love
you I love you too baby do it you got to
do it you're going to kill him br oh my
God D I guess immediately
wow anger will get you
very far yeah yeah use that Ang now he
is boiling come on now you love him no I
love you yeah right I had to say that I
always love you bro let her die bro I'm
sorry she playing the field right now
she's try it's the chick that [__] me in
your bed 2 days ago with one of our life
she not worth it man she not worth it
wow oh wa yeah they're going to okay
this is some deadly tea right
now this seesaw is also a te-a yeah
damn going die right in
half oh Killen Tina for the
public o that's a lot that's a lot
that's a lot all over that's a lot of
blood woo
okay come on now oh my God damn there
was the 3D yep there it oh I don't want
it y'all I don't want it all the way in
half dud yeah she's gone thank God she
died I was like girl can you just die
already oh see see it does say we get a
little Saw 3D yeah okay little tease of
it all right oh
God previously on saw
oh she was right there still oh wow she
girl you running away he he get out of
that that cheat great God yeah he's
doing some Joker action
now SE it up
buddy that's that looks great good work
there that won't scar nope definitely
not definitely not going to get infected
jigsaw Widow what do she want all she
said was that she didn't trust the FBI
uhhuh and she didn't trust homicide she
just wants to talk to you the guy kind
of looks like Christian Bale a little
bit yeah I'm Matt Gibson Internal
Affairs why do you want immunity miss
duck my husband John had an accomplice
this person will go on killing until
he's stopped you know him and he
definitely knows you he's detective Mark
Hoffman your
brother you swear to be totally open you
tell me everything no matter how person
a private I'll give you evidence do we
have a deal oh yeah yeah we have a deal
I feel like something bad's going to
happen
yeah oh he's going off the grid okay
okay he's going rogue it's going dark
live with Bobby Dagan well you're quite
the national phenomenon these days
aren't you thank you who the hell are
you do you remember him no now you
survived a trap created by the infamous
jig Saw Killer correct yes ma'am we're
going to have a flashback I just
remember the feeling of waking up
trapped two hooks into my pectoral
muscles something inside me started to
grow something from from from the bottom
of my soul what I decided to live I
found a strength that I thought had long
since expired and I yanked and when I
got to the top I just ripped something
feels off yeah I feel like he's lying
why are they keep looking at each other
because I had just survived I was reborn
oh he wrote a book that's why he's here
yeah he probably just read the book and
just decided to write a book based off
jigsaws book Bobby's lifechanging
experience comes to Auditorium this week
I'm gonna guess he's a fraud and because
of this experience he's actually going
to get put into a jigsaw trap where was
fake finished a k I just didn't want to
push it she was there for your whole
recovery without the acknowledgement
without the the kiss the audience is
going to have any kind of emotional
connections this feels gross I don't
like this yeah we got the jigsaw
Survivor group tomorrow 30 minutes of
FaceTime with other survivors yeah
sounds good more exciting than that no
that much that was weird yeah right that
was
odd unless he has some connection we'll
find out about later yeah cuz I feel
like there usually is some sort of
connection to jigsaw or like the people
that he's he's actually trapping
choosing yeah it's like a a web of
connection whenever he does his
traps okay so he must have captured tuck
and that's what we're about to see now
right yeah seems like
it wow okay yeah oh oh dang tuck is buff
kind of I can only do it
once this isn't even a game you're going
to kill her's just going to kill her
yeah why you have to make it so
elaborate if you're just going to kill
her right like that took a lot of work
sir you built a whole entire track just
for just is he going to stop at the last
second it's going
[Applause]
[Music]
to all of the okay yep yeah she's got a
vivid
imagination I was like this doesn't feel
real yeah like
what come oh
what hello Heaven I want to play ke the
situation you find yourself in is of
your own doing you your girlfriend and
your friends are all racist you get me
out of here racists yes oh okay yeah
kill them but today it is you who will
run scare your pathetic friends follow
your every word huh therefore you will
be the only one capable of saving them
and yourself 30 seconds the Jacks
holding up this car will
fall setting off a deadly chain of
events you must tear yourself away from
the seat to which you are
glued you must pull the red lever before
you you will learn that we are all the
same color on the inside do you think
this is the cops game or do you think
this is a game that John pre-assigned
him before he died pre dead
yeah okay I don't
know it sounded a lot like John but I
guess they all kind of sound the same
I'm so
concerned I know right oh I hope they
all don't die in a really horrible way
you racist
[Laughter]
[__] oh my God bro use the steering
wheel if you actually want to do it pull
yourself with your
muscles is he trying that oh my God
that's gnarly yeah oh bye-bye everybody
I bet they're going to like if he can't
do it like her head's going to come off
and fly towards the camera cuz oh
right cuz it's like a chain of events so
I'm like okay she gets crushed those oh
and then the car takes off cuz the Jack
goes she gets crushed car takes off his
tongue gets pulled out and he smashes
into the guy in front of him yeah okay
that's what we think
damn that back though H that back
[Music]
though a little too
late
oh my
god oh oh
oh that was that was a mighty CH chain
reaction that was wild
whoa oh God the 3D organs I don't want
it I don't need it oh oh rip Chester
that was obligatory that was had nothing
to do with the rest of the movie they
had to do it do they had to do it oh
it's the cup
everything I see no it's the girl it's a
girl girl yeah they're
everywhere and they remind me of what I
went through what jigsaw did to me oh
group of jigsa yeah it's a group therapy
tell me what happened
[Music]
next what are all these traps that we
didn't see in the previous six movies
what the hell is this just going to be
flashbacks of ones that are like oh oh
he was abusive I tried to stop it before
but it wasn't until that moment that's
the lady secretary the old lady old lady
next to her oh oh from the last movie
yeah oh it's a bunch of [__] he had
to die for you to leave him you want to
know the best thing that happened to me
after having to cut off my own
arm we saw this oh yeah we remember this
mhm is handicap parking at the damn oh H
I am simply here to illustrate the fact
that a traumatic experience such is the
kind that each one of us him he's the
the guy on the so they added some people
from lastau in here if you look around
at all of these people taking their
lives for
granted eventually they all that's I was
say their experience yeah see they're
all okay yeah yeah yeah you know what I
I I'd like everybody to have a look at
oh yeah I was like do you still have
nipples sir we're all strong enough to
go through one more game for $110
million that's that's what that is okay
that doesn't look that bad comparativ
does not look that bad at all but since
then I have found someone who has truly
become my
rock oh now we get to see the act of the
hug and the kiss
Jo love you yeah baby
exploitation it's all planned and script
who is it it's him who it's it's uh it's
Wesley to be able to sustain such a
traumatic experience wait no maybe it's
not no you're right in that Grizzly ass
that's his voice it's a remarkable feet
indeed yeah yeah yeah you're right
you're right if not a little
perverse how grateful we are to be part
of your promotional
DVD oh okay so what's with the creepy
guy with the game someone I should know
about no no no no he's been at these
meetings longer than I have he's he's
fine he's an OG yo
baby oh is she already
dead Jo his girlfriend yeah oh he got
kidna I think I called it I think I
called it he ain't been through [__] you
did he about to now
yeah what do you
think why why this display you mean why
why oh yeah
oh now like why you
asking it's a
murder God
damn could you look at that see for
yourself get forensics in here tell them
to haul ass this needs to be dusted for
Prince why is that toilet paper all on
the
floor what's up with that what's going
on there you need to take some business
before he left that evidence F you need
to sanitize your station homie
uhhuh
[Music]
help
survive hello Bobby I want to play the
game based upon your Story of Survival
many have hated in your cause but few
know the truth you and I both know you
have never been in a trap all it yep
yeah the cage you find yourself in will
symbolize your rebirth chy no Joyce what
are you doing with the
liar she a liar too I know series of
obstacles to obtain access to your wife
if you fail to reach her before the
clock runs out she
will okay what's the game
here oh now I see so elaborate okay that
looked
[Music]
cool the more elaborate these get it
becomes harder to believe that one guy
did this by himself right right you're
like how did you build all that exactly
hell no also where is he getting these
locations exactly this looks like a
church like an old church yeah I see
that was John A Real Estate Mogul like
what the hell I mean those spikes are
far enough away from each other I'd just
be like one foot easily down than the
other or you could do that too yeah
that's that's smart that's probably what
he's doing is smarter yeah there we go
you did it but we all know that's not
it's not the end of the game that's not
it City stays crippled in fear from the
jiging chilling new words from the
latest Survivor provide a reminder oh so
we're saying here's his flashback why he
did it this horrible event was happening
to me is that the wife that pure moment
of absolute horror gave me light and as
wrong as this may seem I'm better for
enduring it I'm grateful it happened to
me and I wish the same for everyone like
me the news would not hold this long
something like that doesn't get you to
change your perspective on life I don't
know what will and if those people
weren't soed up after their games they'd
make a mint selling their stories I'd
have to imagine someone would do this in
real life if this was like oh this the
case yeah it's still wild to think that
there's all these traps we didn't see
that happened in between movies I guess
well here's my problem that was left for
me and your fingerprints were all over
it your fingerprints what you didn't
mention that it was because you tried to
kill him I don't you're crazy you know
that I knew you were crazy the minute I
laid eyes on you crazy I don't buy this
guy as a car I really don't buy him as
an actor right now's going on he was
fine in the other scene he was
absolutely fine this scene I'm like I am
no sir how did you get this
job I'm happy had the same thought I was
like it makes me mad because I'm like
I'm an actor and I think I could do
better this was sent here addressed to
Jill Hoffman knows our location God damn
it God damn it this all seems not good
oh
god oh all right okay you're protecting
her this despite the fact that she had
Direct knowledge throughout which makes
her complicit in every death give her to
me the game stops and no one else dies
if not everyone dies and you'll be to
blame whoa whoa what is going on
here please please no what the
hell Bobby oh she knows him Bobby oh is
that that's the assistant lady that we
saw earlier friend oh okay do something
play me play me she has been your
publicist for years knowing your lives
today she will be rewarded for her
silence in the X-ray you will see a key
oh it's got to be which will shut off
her device you have one minute to pull
the fish hook from her stomach or else
the four spikes will penetrate her
throat the spikes will also Advance each
time the decibel level in this room rise
choice is
your oh God girl I'd be like don't
scream calm down yeah shut up shut
up stay with me
okay let him pull that [__] out of there
it's going to hook is it going to hook
she going to die bro she going to die
you're going to R her stomach open I
hate it shut
[Applause]
up pull it through your finger just like
keep your mouth closed oh my God how do
you even do that
[Music]
[Applause]
man I hate it I really hate
it oh god oh that sound not sound effect
how do you even do that how do you even
get
that wouldn't it kill her oh
God oh God I don't want it I don't want
it I don't want
it I get points for
creativity it hurts me fast fast fast
hurts just yank it out already I can't
be doing
this so gross so oh God that's nasty oh
God that's nasty what did you oh did you
get it did he get it I hate it all oh
and you're dead and you're dead yeah you
pulled it but she's dead she's going to
die just give up at this
point why would you just shut the
up my
God oh my God oh that one was really
gross y'all it was really gross but you
know what I was thinking the entire time
how did this man get access to an xme
machine oh
right you're a fugitive On The Run yeah
you're right you're right well we
probably it from from jigsaw right
aren't those things like huge like did
you get an xray machine I mean they were
held up in that hospital for a long time
oh his wife his wife's a doctor but she
he's not working with her though cuz
she's you mean the yeah the new guy but
I'm saying like jigsaw probably had one
in his freaking storage right from his
wife maybe I just want to say I love
your book so much it feels like a
flashback still I don't know why like
the main events what we're watching like
the this is definitely a flashback yes
you think this is a flashback within a
flashback is that what you're saying
like cuz you were asking about the X-ray
thing yeah that I'm like oh this is
a your name sir oh oh see okay with an
age without an age doesn't matter and in
ancient Egypt if you were speaking under
oath you were required to say if I'm
lying take me to the quaries that mean
anything to you no sir you're subject to
a period of enslavement nice picture but
I don't know
we've met so I thought they wrote the
book after he was already caught see
that's why I said like the flashback
thing cuz all of this is it feels like
you think this is a John trap not a not
a cop trap like not something the cops
doing right like I'm you know how they
messed with the story lines in the other
one or I mean the plot the timelines
yeah that's why I'm like cuz it doesn't
make sense with what's going on
currently right here right okay right
that's was taken from a security camera
downtown the guy's name is Bobby denan
familiar oh he's a jigsaw Survivor oh
this is happening at the same time okay
okay I guess he is just that thirsty for
the game this
man this man is actively on the run but
he's like oh I I got to keep testing got
got to add in another game got to get
revenge for my boy
John also I can't not see it this dude
looks like a hybrid between Ian McGregor
and and um Ed Norton Ed Norton's yes
that is a perfect mix that's exactly
what it looks like Mommy get me out of
here
Mommy I would love to just arrive to A
victim who is just like we've all read
his books we know what's going on and
for them to cly be like please find a
way to get me out of here right they're
just chilling waiting for it to happen
waiting for them to be free is your
lawyer who swore an oath of Ethics but
chose to see no evil once her device
begins to rotate it will PE Pi her eyes
and mouth if you don't delay its
movement it's it's what I called in the
other movie lift the bars to the highest
position if you do nothing she will
whine to her death before the clock runs
out terara the the the publicist will
speak no evil she see no evil so the
other guy is going to be hear no evil I
said that in the other movie you did you
did but this is definitely what they're
doing now this is
yes
ooh okay
lift
lift I
mean oh it just like
3D what does it do it just pauses it
right or is it I guess cuz I'm like
what's the point unless it actually
stops itbe has to hold it for a certain
amount of time I guess until the the
time runs out
or in her mouth too I guess yeah my God
how much time do we have left okay yeah
just get it over with she leaned into it
she really did it looked like she did
oh growth these ones are gnarly yeah for
real they like let's just turn it up to
11 haven't been this gory in the past
few yeah it hasn't and I'm like one
after the other hasn't been this gory
since I would say three yeah the three
is when like the guy's limbs were
turning and then pulled off right yeah
yeah the her rib cage was open that was
hello Gibson I don't blame you for not
giving me Jill talk but you shouldn't
let an old Grudge Cloud your judgment
look to where you're being led look
beyond the crossroad to the clear Dawn I
get it let's go there's something about
this one that seems very TVV or or
something it's a little Hy yeah
something about it um feels a little off
to
me all are we doing hear no evil that
doesn't look like it don't move where
the hell are you do you know where Joyce
is he has to hear right he follow his
voice or some [__] meaning like walk
yeah walk across yeah don't move hey
give it down B you scared
me across from you is your closest
friend he knows all your sins yet he
acts as though he hears no evil you had
it he called it you must get it to him
over the last span between you if the
new suround Kale's neck is not removed
within 60 seconds a winch will be
engaged feel like all his friends die so
of try your best but but uh I want you
to shuffle to your right I need you to
head out on that plank yes where does he
get these buildings from that's right
like this is like he's buying up real
estate right like he
must
the water there why scare just just a
little goof you know just to tease him a
little bit oh my
God on to it feel it with your
foot that looks like rotting wood don't
put your foot on that no now just reach
up and out in front of you and grab a
grab a hold of that key
kid nope you're not
okay does this guy have pleather pants
on I think he does I am distracted now I
are they because if they are he's
definitely not make it through this trap
he's not making it he's not going going
to make you through this trap with pants
yeah
man I've got to throw you the key he's
going to drop it he's going to drop it
of course you can't see [__] God you're
done dude to oh my
God oh God did we need the closeup of it
I don't know that we did everybody in
the audience saw that coming just jump
to get it oh oh he's hanging bye-bye
buddy bye bye bye bye bye okay this is
the least violent of the deaths oh so
he's just okay that was pretty quick
this is where he saved my
life drop the
gun yeah I saw that coming also I'm like
would a junkie really just freeze like
that shot him in the back too this place
was called Crossroads look beyond the
crossroads man he killed was released
from Clear Dawn psychiatric hospital
when the state shut it down that's where
the game is being
played I love how characters in movies
make
connections yeah well in this one
specifically there's jumping out there
jumping on that limb or off that limb
before you is the door that leads to
your wife however you must first make a
choice as you may have guessed your
decision will be as difficult as pulling
teeth yeah okay to shut up a lock before
you requires a four n combination
numbers have been etched onto two of
your teeth look to the Chart as a
reference for which teeth to pull and in
which order to enter get a pulling I
thought he was going to be like pull out
all your teeth so you can't lie
anymore he he went light on them with
this one yeah he did I don't want it I
really the sound I knew it was coming
and I don't like
it the police okay they're already there
yeah cuz he he found it based off of his
little
riddle it's really the sound here that's
doing it for
us oh God that's a lot of blood that's
there's so much going on I found where
that EG came from where a business
called Pete's Auto Body on 58th
Street
damn all right you use some wall
leverage to get it out I guess
so I wonder if this is a a number two
situation where they're coming way after
the fact what do you mean so remember
how in two we were watching all the
stuff and it happened like hours ago and
it's like yeah like it was
yeah something I will say about this one
it feels more fast-paced than the last
one yeah the the pacing is good I just
there's some something off about the the
tone of it I feel like with the actors
some of them some of them for sure I'm
like I takes me right out of it I don't
think we've had any major complaints so
far as far as acting goes we haven't but
that one cop it's kind
of also how does wesle playing all of
this they showed us that that thing in
the beginning for a reason
right
not just so he can make a cameo he has
to have some sort of role in this
Huffman Breeze I want you to slowly put
your hands in the air it's just jigsaw
it's a doll or is it the pig mask we
haven't seen the pig mask yet we did cuz
he oh yeah you're right yeah very brief
but he made a
cameo B oh my God Jurassic Park vibes
she is your trophy and she has seen the
good in your message despite its
dishonest Beginnings what's he talking
about she doesn't know oh she does she
thinks it was real yeah but everyone
else is in on it you must hoist yourself
with these chains and connect the
extension cords above you before the
clock expires dang dude spectral muscles
can easily support your way so I ask you
Bobby when you Embrace every day as if
it is your last should be easy you've
done it before come on stab them in
we're losing time buddy you've got three
minutes nobody's here is it
jigsaw
O Okay I
lied I was never in a trap I'm your
wife Happ you lie to me it's the whole
reason we got together in the first
place cuz I thought you were a survivor
what's the
twist bag the bodies getting back to the
Corner's office right away he's been
watching us the whole
time oh so we could steal the body
okay you get every available officer
back to the station I'm
sorry
damn see you later dude who oh boy wow
wow
that's
tough using a body bag or is it him yeah
okay yeah that's why I figured like he's
got to get in there
man oh and of course he wants to kill
him he was the guy that said I know how
to tell the jigsaw puzzles apart right
the last one yeah yeah
yeah a dang you all got to go who's
going to get him he can't win yeah maybe
he can again what's the what's your
final game here man what's your play
door locked we
Lo what is
that of acid or gas yeah
yeah she's been on a stabbing spree man
like yeah this man's doing stuff like a
video game jeez I love you you have I
feel like we've been here for 10 minutes
right seriously like the clock an hour
ago said 4 minutes so let's go okay
Gibson she get a knife too oh no she
just going to strangle just a nice
Suffocation
there oh okay he switched it up switched
it up at the last
minute oh my God hell
no I feel like those hooks aren't de
deep enough F of your skin would just
rip through I know just rip right off
[Music]
right this feels like Law and Order yeah
it's back to that TV feel talking
[Music]
about oh oh all this give to
Jill yep yep yep yep
yep running on pure adrenaline right now
I know right just like real quick
going to shoot right yeah nice okay
right in the damn face is there anybody
left to save her at this point like [__]
no I mean they're all dead yeah she's
pretty screwed I've been looking for
you what does he do he just leaves her
there I'll be looking for you what that
me I've been looking for you oh I've
been thought he said I'll I'm like what
is he going to do okay he just like sets
her free to continue to play this C I'll
be looking for you and I was like this
would of course they would be
like oh we locked
it he's been doing this for like 5 hours
like come on man the longest minutes the
end of it of him trying to do
this you can do
it
oh
god that hurt yeah felt that felt that
saw that coming saw that
coming yeah your wife's dead man yeah I
mean what are you going to do you're
going to jump up there you got 8 seconds
it's done it's all over
oh W wa what this is so like this unb
cost $3
million oh my God oh my God that's the
worst she's just going to simmer all
right Bo okay buddy yeah like you can't
oh God right there's no way he he just
set that up like that's ridiculous
yeah oh now he was going to put the shop
on face damn
damn oh God yeah here we go back to the
beginning oh God our face is already
coming off I buddy I would just look
away this is just run just say you're
sorry and leave the room yeah you got to
just get out of there that is rough you
lost everybody
damn oh is he going to tie a shotgun up
to her like he was remember his his
first game was the shotgun move I think
he's going to put the trap on her thing
on her that makes more sense but
I oh he's heating up too just leave the
room buddy she's gone this going
Inferno wait is it the oh the old one
why did you okay okay yeah the OG the OG
that's um what's her names
amandas all
right
I feel like at this point this movie
would do some goofy [__] like say John's
still alive and he just comes into the
room right and he's like I had to die in
order for you to realize your final
test this entire series was a game for
you
Hoffman the fact that Hoff's about to
live and get away with it is weird right
it's weird man it's not right I mean she
she did want him to stop doing it yeah
but she didn't know about all of
it
D that is so gross that's rough that's
in addition to the nine police employees
killed tonight Jill tuck the white
serial killer John Kramer has been found
dead and nobody knew it was him cuz
everybody involved is dead is dead yet
again so I guess I guess Wesley was just
a cameo just just because I okay that
makes me mad cuz I thought we were going
to be with him more I love him as an
actor he he was good he's great um this
is
dumb he just used to Walk Away
3D oh oh oh oh oh do we have more
copycats that we didn't see coming oh
oh wait what's her nuts is it what's her
nuts does she she die the woman that got
the stuff in her face Wesley it's Wesley
it's totally it's toally him
totally okay called that [__] you did
good oh that's to Wesley is that you are
perhaps my greatest
asset without you my worst would not
have been
possible what
he joined
him what he's Someone putting keys in
bodies are you for real right now dude
she'll be
perfect what what this is dumb this is
this is
dumb oh
wow he's a whole ass family watch over
Jill I've showed you a lot of places
there is one that will be perhaps the
most meaningful to you the original room
yeah I don't think
so oh 3D 3D
yeah oh
wow so dumb oh
god oh look there's his foot this is his
old crumpled up foot you could take your
foot buddy as a little souvenir a little
momento get your little foot back yeah
little footsy wsy game
over game
[Music]
over okay
K we we did it we did it I don't I'm
curious to see what else Kevin grter has
done we saw the saws we saw the saws man
wow and there were no more movies after
this you know what's crazy is I'm like
the bodies are still there because
location one must have been what now the
only location that they still the cops
don't know where it is even though all
these books and all this stuff with all
the bodies has been caught right
Hereafter right it do make sense that's
location one is still untouched they
haven't figured it app well it's at the
one house but remember it's underneath
like in a tunnel somewhere right right
but still I'm like come on right I mean
if they haven't found right the bodies
but okay all right
okay I just I feel
like I feel I feel man like to put I
think his name the ACT we like Carrie L
was is that his name I think that the
guy at the end that were like what he's
the doctor I think to put him as the guy
who put the keys in and sewed up the
eyes I'm like no jigsaw would do that he
built machines to take people's limbs
off like we didn't need to add a doctor
in here who was like I know how to Sol
up this precisely it's like no I don't
think jigsaw would would put would
compromise his position by teaching a
guy a lesson and then going join me and
and and help me kill these people by
putting keys in him just like how I said
and I'm still upset but from the last
one I thought why did he train this cop
to go through all the killing and train
him we saw him go through all of them to
be like you're going to overcome it if
at the end of it that he was just going
to like set him up to be killed right by
his ex-wife was trying to kill him
there's just a lot there's a lot of
loopholes I mean the games were gnarly
this one I didn't like there's some
acting that I thought was just really
under par for what was going on here
which took me way out of it and I don't
and I think that one actor like you said
he we liked him in the one scene that
has a lot to do with Direction mostly it
could have been the director being like
you got to go wild here and point around
I don't know there was just a a overall
Vibe here that it felt a little more
underwhelming the games are still cool I
like what I saw um that that was it was
still so gory and nasty but yeah there's
something a little off about it that I
go yeah not not my favorite take it away
take it away oh man okay I have a lot of
thoughts on this um okay let's start
with the good let's start with the
Positive uh I
liked isolated I liked the games in this
one I thought they were the most gory
and most creative we've seen since the
third movie uh I liked the premise of
this guy who was a fake I think this the
first time we've seen in these mov
movies where somebody has to try to save
people they care about but even even
though he fails at at every attempt and
we don't know what happens to him at the
end I don't think he dies I think he
just he's just in there watching his
wife beaten up so yeah I'll say that was
I liked that just on the surface if you
think about it too deeply it's going to
crumble apart but
uh yeah that the fact that this is not a
jigs this is not a jigsaw puzzle this is
just we're open-ended we're open-ended
we're just doing it now we're how does
he have an x-ray machine I that doesn't
make sense I thought they were going to
get to that and answer your question
when we were like oh it's the doctor of
course like cuz I first thought the wife
she's a doctor would have an X macine
and I thought for sure they'll show I
think maybe they just want us to like
just assume because he was the one
putting the keys in there that that
doctor had one right yeah maybe I don't
know there's a lot of stuff in this
movie that didn't make sense uh the
acting was rough some of it was rough
most most of it was good except for most
of it was serviceable except for that
one cop I don't know what the hell he
was doing uh yeah man this
movie I don't know it was fun also it it
was fun but it wasn't good I will say it
was they didn't utilize all the
information in which we've learned in a
way that's cohesive and for it to be
this culminating culminating chapter for
all six or seven of these movies was a
little
underwhelming or just a little
disappointing in the fact that you know
I don't I don't think these movies have
been as good since John the original
jigsaw was part of it I think those th
first three movies that trilogy probably
stands the best cuz once we get four and
Hoffman's like our our new guy it just
it doesn't hit the same but I like six
though I will say outside of those first
20 minutes I know that we kind of kind
of slow but I liked I like the majority
of six got a Twist there we got a Twist
here but it was sort of like what why
would he he didn't really need that guy
to do the stuff and that's what they're
trying to do the flip floor of like the
doctor that's how you got the keys in
there okay that that's the part that
gets me right the fact that this doctor
the whole time has been part of it
Hoffman didn't know he was a part of it
Amanda didn't know he was a part of it
the audience didn't know he was a part
of it and that one felt like a twist for
twitch sake because like oh we got to do
something crazy cuz all of these movies
have major twists but yeah it just
didn't track and I was like okay for
Amanda join she would have known that
that doctor was doing the key stuff the
whole time right she was with him always
yeah she was rolling him around
everywhere he went well I kind we've
kind of learned that John kind of like
had people isolated let certain people
know what but also I don't I don't think
the 3D was used very well or maybe
because of the fact we're watching it in
in 2D but just from what we were seeing
some of it was a little like a little
hokey yeah like the saw going out at the
end of the thing and you know what
really killed me is that there was an
exposure and lighting change from the
room to where he throws it and then you
see it land outside in the on the ground
the lighting is different oh wow but I
mean that's okay like the room is
fluorescent lighting maybe out there's a
little dark but I was like they didn't I
don't know it just I don't know it
seemed weird that the lighting was it
was very different I would have been
like y'all got to match that color a
little bit better so it seems like it's
at the same time y'all got to fix this
up man this is it just yeah plus we kind
of said it during the reaction the the
actual scenes with the cops also looked
very TV again like this movie came out
in 2010 this is a Fran exactly and the
acting this is a franchise that's firmly
established while the MCU is running
well we've had movies like Inception and
the in the dark knight at this point and
it still looks so cheap and I'm like
that's crazy I'll cann't put a little
bit more love a little bit more budget
into this movie but I feel like they did
do a lot like that's why I was like they
did a ton of budget where I'm like the
track and her her her all these
flashbacks of like that we didn't need
to see in the help group like why did we
see that one lady's flashback she let
the husband go he gets cut up by saws we
see her on the track she gets cut in
half a fullon one where he's like sure
he's in the cage then we have the wood
and then finally at the end she gets
burned alive and I'm like this movie to
me seems that had a larger budget but it
it's underperforming for me and that is
the part that I it bugs me yeah it
didn't utilize it well in all the right
places who's funding this not the movie
but who's funding these project come and
contact me and Aaron I'm an I am an
actor and a
producer just give me a 116th of the
money and let's see what we can do let's
see let's make let's make
magic I mean yeah anyway I cut you off
continue you were saying something else
no I think I don't even remember where I
was I think just the fact that Wesley
got involved at the end just kind of was
like a Hail Mary like we got to have
some sort of twist for this movie H the
the guy from the beginning we got to
make it all all one uniform story
because we got to tie it back to the the
beginning chapter and I think if I
remember correctly like I haven't
watched or seen any like synopsis or
anything wanted to stay away from
spoilers but I saw that I think the next
movie it's not called saw 8 it's called
jigsaw and that one was made in 2017 oh
that's a that's a that's seven years
later yeah each one of these we've
watched has been like back to back
exactly yeah from 2004 through 2010
because after this one they were like
maybe I'll need to take a break right
cuz this is not we're reaching too far
we're trying to come up with these bait
and switches and r RS at the end which
this to me was you guys could have I
feel like in the room when the writers
pitched this or it could be the writers
had a had a decent script and the up
Abes were like no you got to bring
somebody back I don't you know what I
mean like oh that guy from the first one
that'd be a big reveal let be crazy guys
come on come on we got do better better
B
reach yeah I I will say I think this
would have
been fun to see in the theaters but I
don't think it would have been good I I
think the first two movies are
legitimately good movies everything
after that has kind of been just like
okay this is the next chapter everything
after that has felt incomplete and I
feel like the beginning of that
incomplete storytelling with the the
Cliffhangers started in two but I think
two had a good enough story in of itself
to be sustainable as a satisfying
experience but everything else has been
like okay we just got to keep this going
to get to the next piece of it and now
we've finally gotten to what's supposed
to be the final chapter and it's just
like it's gotten away from itself you
know it's it we we've lost the purpose
of what the original intention was
behind these movies and even though it's
still doing the Trap thing it's not it's
doing it for the sake of doing it not
for the sake of what was originally
intended it's kind
of I don't know if ironic is the right
word but the fact that maybe he he was
killed because his games got perverted
you know and as the games got perverted
the movies got more perverted with with
its intention and like how cuz it
started off as like this thriller and
like this mystery of like what's going
on and then it kind of just got more
into like we got to make we got to up
the antee we got to like raise the
stakes we got to make the traps crazier
and like granted maybe that's something
you want to see as you watch these
movies but I feel like you got to have a
strong story encompassing that or like
accompanying that as you go along and it
just didn't man but I like I said I had
fun with it I don't think it was good I
think it's definitely better than what
was the boring one we watched was that
five yeah it's around those numbers the
one where was like cop versus cop where
the other cop got killed five I think it
was five okay I would
say if we CU obviously they probably
intended this to be the end of them
before they started to continue with
Jigsaw and spiral and now saw X right uh
I was thinking as we're watching it I
was like okay if I had to rank them just
based off of the original intention for
how they saw the series going I'd
probably put saw two first saw one
second saw six saw
three saw
four six then five well you said six on
the third I take back I me seven I at
seven he's just saying I'm saying sh I'm
saying everything and nobody's going to
keep track they haven't watched it 1 2 3
4 5 well maybe they have they watch it
they've been watching it I've been
reading the comments watching it with us
yeah oh good everyone people watching we
we have some okay we have some steady
followers look at that so he meant four
five he meant four five seven two yeah
213 no yeah 21 six
3 457 right
475 475 okay it's numbers you got them
um listen I agree with him it's just
it's
really I mean um that's the passcode to
get in um no but the storytelling I
think it's really just the the in the
beginning especially with one is just is
teaching these people a lesson but
staying with them long enough to where
we actually care and the last few movies
we stay not long enough with anyone for
us to care enough whether we lose them
or they die yeah um it's just sort of
like yeah they did a bad thing we know
it's coming for you cuz we understand
the game and the process but we haven't
sat in it or any of the games which we
did with one and two which made it
really satisfying we got to know these
people at the core of who they are we
got to see them interact with each other
and then figure it out and lately with
three I think three and through they
just send one person and they're going
through a bunch of games and I for me
I'm like I get it that audiences want to
see bigger and batter and maybe more
Gore but I find it that like are we
really sitting in an audience and
testing that that that's that is the
more entertaining story of it I'm not
sure I do like seeing the the the traps
are different we we have to switch it up
I totally get it but I think it would be
really fun also to go back to like a
lower budget feel where it's like you
got to deal with the people and and
maybe make sure the traps there's got to
be something different and I understand
that but maybe it doesn't need to be so
extreme to get our attention because I
really like sitting with the people in
their story and then seeing the rest of
it versus um seeing a bunch of plot
lines like the racist people that was a
cool kill I get it but like wouldn't it
would have been so satisfying if we had
had to sit in their story for a minute
and see like how he got them in that
position to then kill him it would have
been so exciting to be like you guys are
going to die yeah it still was but we
didn't we just there just hasn't been
enough juice to lead us up to a lot of
these kills within the last few films
it's still a lot of fun it's fun to
watch great G I love that the public one
in the very beginning the girl with the
two guys is cool all the stuff looks it
looks awesome I just I'm not as engaged
story-wise and you guys know like acting
that that made me a little upset I was
like what's this guy doing that will
always take me out of it just as an
actor and then secondly story and plot
line like do I do I believe them and do
I like feel for them and then this one I
didn't really so I'm going to just rate
it for you I know we've been chatting
for a minute over here still still fun
like I'm excited to watch the others
there's just I mean I'll always try to
be honest with you all of like yeah not
great so I'll put this one
I you know I'm going to go because it's
still fun like the kills the traps cool
I'm just I'm going to go with a six but
the there's the stuff that I mentioned
and it may not be an actor thing could
be a direction thing I don't know brings
it down to a six for me for this one
yeah that's funny that's actually what I
was thinking I was thinking about a six
too yeah I think I think we rated five
of six so I think they're like neck and
neck as far as ratings go as far as like
the lower tier yeah yeah yeah not my
favorite I had I can say I had fun with
the experience but it's like one of
those things it got some to the point
where it was like so bad it's good kind
of thing or so bad it's fun so yeah I
would say that it's like a almost a
parody of itself at this point but you
know I I can say for that experience
alone I would give it a six yeah I like
that so that's what we're doing but
we're going to watch S8 n and the 10
wait this is seven right seven eight
nine and 10 we have three more baby you
know what I should leave cuz you know
I'm tired and I thought we were watching
no I'm kidding okay I knew what this one
was we got three more after this we love
you guys don't forget to leave a like
leave a comment ring the bell um tell us
how cool we are and other stuff I don't
know leave whatever you like we love you
thank you for being here you got any
last words
Aaron woo we love you and we'll see you
on the next one
[Music]
bye